uh next speaker is Joseph Urban one of
the leads of our of his project
focus and Ai and reasoning he is linking
in his efforts machine learning with
reasoning that's quite Noble approach
and unique pioneering so I don't want to
talk anymore it's his turn and his time
to explain what was done thank you very
much thank you
um so
thanks everybody for coming here
um
and I was I've been working here now for
let me think seven
eight years
I initially came with an ERC
consolidatory Grant
and somehow
Professor Marie implicated me into even
a larger Grant so so at some point I was
I was doing uh
two two big Brands together luckily
there was sort of an overlapping uh
theme there
and I should say a lot of what
I will speak about has already been uh
sort of introduced by Holger House's
talk like um like basically for 25 years
I I have tried to combine
uh two areas of what I think forums like
human or scientific thinking
and that's learning and deduction
and to to start this with a funny slide
so you can you can read this a bit
uh so so if you
if you if nothing else you remember from
the stock remember this book logical mix
and epic search for Truth by Alexis doc
serious
which is an amazing Comics book written
some 10
maybe more years ago now
about the life of Bertram Russell
and about the basically creation
about like a major evolution in Science
and Mathematics which many people do not
understand uh even mathematicians
sometimes do not understand it so
so there was this guy called leibnized
some I'm not sure if Holger mentioned
him or not I think so
who who had a very
crazy dream
apart from doing amazing things like
inventing calculus to together with
Newton
uh that one day
humans who disagree be be it philosopher
be it economists be it lawyers be it
mathematicians be it physicists be
computer scientists
will be able to resolve their
disagreement by calculation
computation
computation wasn't defined and like they
knew how to calculate some things he was
the co-creator of calculus at the time
but by he had this crazy vision
uh that one day we we will have like
perfect computational means
to to decide major questions disputes
Etc
and this thing
uh so Bertram Russell is a great
logician and philosopher who
participated in this revolution in
basically in the beginning of the 20th
century
where people basically embedded
mathematics and by extension physics and
hard sciences that are modeled by by
mathematics
into logic
and they didn't know yet that symbolic
logic
will be the sort of substrate
from which computation will emerge what
you today call computers
are symbolic
symbolic logic machines
uh so so many of you have been many of
you are younger than me have been born
to computers it's certainly in phones
and normal thing for for many of you
but whenever you are playing with your
phone doing something on your computer
you are doing symbolic logic
I'll
so
this
in this particular uh picture from from
the book
uh Russell is saying like
what what does it mean uh
that uh like like he dreamed uh the the
lightness his dream and and he didn't
uh he didn't achieve it well what he
means there is that like during his
lifetime uh we we really didn't get
there like we we started to
play with computers
and we sort of barely by the time he
died
started to do mathematics on computers
like really like reasonably advanced
mathematics
but but we haven't really moved to to
the more advanced territories like
physics the tall Holger uh mentioned
and to say nothing about like law about
legalism language Adam is sort of aiming
aiming for this like various ontologies
Etc but it's a dream and and this dream
is sort of coming uh I I think it's sort
of unavoidable at this moment with all
the technology that we have
you you may think that AI is giving us
now with the chair GPT Etc the sort of
bad side by like the confusing side like
it can it can do
uh very very confused quote unquote
reasoning which isn't reasoning by by
any reasonable metric
uh but like with all these technologies
that we have it it seems that
um like computational mathematics like
proving hard mathematical theorems
is really getting
achievable at this point
with that it's achievable like all the
uh like let's say physics and computer
science which which relies on
mathematics
and I I think what is even achievable
even though that will be harder because
it's it's not exactly a hard science
it's it's really very precise uh logical
layer for things like legal reasoning or
ethical reasoning I I think the
technology is really really getting
there
oh so so so this project was
to a large extent about this about sort
of trying to combine the two areas uh of
what's a human thinking
on computers to to sort of develop
Technologies
that that help that sort of
the help the human or machine reasoners
to find a way to find the proofs to find
justifications
by combining them with the intuition
that you can learn that you that you can
learn when you solve some problems and
you learn from those Solutions Etc
so so that's in a nutshell
the the project was sort of bigger than
than that so there are quite a few
people they're very seniors
juniors
administrators Affiliated researchers
partner institutions in the Netherlands
and in Austria
are valued constant contacts there and
probably over 40 40 visitors like over
over this time
you can try to see yourself here or CeCe
your colleagues there these are our
valued team team members
and the this is just a plain listing of
all the visitors which if you if you
know something about the field of
automated theorem proving and
interactive theorem proving you you will
definitely recognize the names let's say
all of the names at least on the various
three to four lines like really the we
we managed to to get here
almost everybody who means something in
in the field of automated Theory
improving interactive here improving so
so that's already was really amazing to
have this possibility to invite these
people here and do do research with them
of
the the topics was as I mentioned uh
like like my core area
is combinations of like deduction of
automated proving with machine learning
uh with that
um
a very interesting topic which we
basically started and which is today
being taken up by researchers
around the world and that's AI companies
like Google and openai and Facebook is
automated formalization
which basically means that you take
a piece of
informally written mathematics like
mathematics written in latex or word or
whatever
and now you you train some machine
Learning System
to to translate that piece of informal
natural language text
into a formal text which you can fully
formally verify by computers so so so
the computer after the translation to to
this formal language I'll show you some
example later
can really say that the the sort of
translated version of this particular
argument is logically correct
uh so so this is
especially today with large language
models or even small language models
the and their combinations with various
like feedback loops that are doing type
checking and semantic checking
uh this is like a very
promising area of research
where it looks like
um instead of what people have been
doing so far in in the field of
verification of mathematics which is
like typing manually a mathematical
statement in some sort of programming
language and then trying to manually
prove it
we will we may have a shot at basically
taking let's say all of the mathematics
which is out there which is like in
various textbooks or articles papers Etc
Iran some sort of reasonably augmented
learning slash type checking semantic
technology that we train in some
feedback loop
and for free or for a much lower effort
than these humans are currently doing
basically translate some non-trivial
a part of all all these big mathematical
texts
and that basically leads to the
sliveness dream that I just mentioned
like suddenly
instead of let's say mathematicians or
physicists or computer scientists
quarreling whether some proof is correct
or incorrect
how to formalize it and how they
actually approve steps uh very
you you well have a technology that will
do this
automatically or semi-automatically
for you like completely like verifying
like even like complicated uh
complicated uh reasonings automatically
and again like
for for those people who think that
large language models are some sort of
Doom that will bring
confusion to the masses
I think this may be one of the cures
like the fact that you will take let's
say you ask some reasonable question
which is at least slightly scientific
like how how would you how would I solve
this let's say mathematical problem or
physics problem
and and the large language model
replies to in some way it may be making
things up it may be correct but if you
manage to translate it
to a strictly logical form you you may
have it you may have a shot at basically
verifying the answer of the large
language model
logically or step by step and if there
is a problem like the the logic
verification systems are good enough to
tell you today like here is The Logical
Gap I I don't see how this that follows
from uh from the steps so so that that's
like a very very interesting area of
research that we started
there there is more like that there are
reasoning areas like Adam pieces working
on ontologies
will be speaking uh later
uh very soon satisfiability module
theories
uh we have people working on complex
systems and artificial eyes we have
people working on theory of systems and
automatic control data science
operations research
optimization
scheduling and real-time systems then
you can dialect and his colleagues
human computer interaction natural
language processing sign language
processing and and some more so so the
project was back so it was a many people
working for six years and it produced
over 100 papers
where more than 50 percent of those very
with International co-authors
I'll I'll just give you some highlights
and then I will go into what I sort of
understand uh most which are like these
combinations of machine learning and
automated deduction
so
in the the project was divided into
three work packages
the the first one was mostly about like
these these combinations of learning and
proving
very basically the main result which I
will show you later
is that we have shown that it is
possible to take the best automated hair
improving systems today which are
extremely well engineered
fast symbolic systems
and make them much better by
augmenting them with machine learning
methods and introducing some sort of
feedback loops where the
machine learning gets better as the CRM
improves more problems
and the theorem query gets better as the
machine learning machine learner which
is sort of advising the the crm3 gets
stronger by training on on these
more and more advanced proofs so so it
sounds easy and maybe simple to today
but basically the main breakthrough we
only did four years ago like before that
it wasn't very clear whether we we have
something or not
uh as I mentioned we did the first
systems for automated formalization and
also for things like automated proposing
of mathematical conjectures and
synthesizing
uh various interesting mathematical
objects
we have one especially Martin Surah who
will be talking yeah later uh some some
victories in automated here improving
competitions
our our valued Affiliated researcher uh
Bob Vero from who is Emeritus at the
University of New Mexico and
Affiliated researcher here
has actually proved some open
conjectures producing very very
non-trivial tools
here at sericon on our machines
basically
that really like resolve some problems
that are interesting for foreign
package two
was added by Zenia Gonzalez who is like
breaking on scheduling problems so so
their results are
in mixed criticality scheduling and for
example they optimize robotic cells or
they they are really applied to the
level of being able to to drive
autonomously these small cars these
formulas that actually have their own
racing competitions that that they are
capable of winning
and then there was a research by
professor svitak and his colleagues
doing AI for smart smart cities
which I think has taken off like
independently or like there's more
funding for for it now here
uh in work package three
we had professor of kuchera
who who is like
one of the best Czech scientists who was
just recently awarded the chesca lava
the the Czech mind
for solving uh long-standing open
problems in control theory
and then we had people from Polson from
Belson
doing work on Linguistics and sign
Linguistics and for example winning
competitions in hand post estimation
etc etc so the the group works
started a very interesting research
in
in complex systems and
I I guess we all hope that tomash will
will get the opportunity to continue
this research because it's uh what what
he is passionate about
oh
so so that was a brief summary
of of the project and I have 10 minutes
to to go a bit deeper and I do not know
how much time I will have for that
so I guess you some of you may recognize
these pictures
so so yesterday we we walked to the
concert
with
one
famous AI researcher
one famous philosopher like his name is
edsalta but this guy and he he just left
today and one famous ontologist who is
over there around peace
and uh it was a funny walk because as
you go through Prague
you you see places where
worked
[Music]
and I I don't know how how many of you
know know this history
but basically like when these people
worked here in 1600s
oh
to some extent to a non-trivial extent
they they started a process that is
called the Scientific Revolution
the the basically development of
scientific method
which
at some point
if you if you sort of
Follow The Line
went through people like Galileo and
Newton and leibniz
uh to to to to development of science to
development of natural philosophy to
development of physics to to development
of other
Sciences or scientists like symbolic
logic and as I said also the development
of computers and to development of
artificial intelligence
so
at that time I I don't know if I have
the slide here of oh
I
I think the
the funny thing
is that at that time
there was such a concentration of smart
people doing things in Prague
that they they were thinking
that this could be some sort of
Singularity so something that people
would call Singularity today that the
world will radically change and it
changed it didn't change so quickly they
started uh 30 Years War and the sort of
slowed down things a lot
uh but like it got to people like Newton
and leibniz
who as I said like they developed
physics and they they all declared all
these crazy ideas about computation
which materialized like it took some
Centuries with example computation maybe
unfortunately because babich babich
wasn't wasn't funded as soon as he
should have
uh but but it basically happened
and
to some extent uh it started
um by people like Braha and Kepler
doing uh what we call today science
doing
analysis of data
proposing conjectures doing computation
with the proposed conjectures
verifying whether the proposed
conjectures were refuting then modifying
them and iterating this process
and the the this is the process
that we today in my project want to
emulate on computers it's it's the
process of scientific method the the
process of doing science basically
and I think if he managed to automate it
like their Visions might come true like
the the the division
of computers
automatically doing superhuman physics
or superhuman computer science
is really crazy like none of us can
think what will happen when machines
will start to develop new laws of
physics for example
oh so I'll move on a bit because some
five minutes down to to the countdown
so I I have already explained quite a
bit of this like
what what we are aiming at
is development of methods that combine
the inductive thinking which is like
learning from examples proposing
explanations conjectures Etc
and basically some sort of deduction
reasoning computation
and designing the mechanisms which
humans have human scientists have in
their minds
but but somehow we don't really have yet
systems that would be as good as human
scientists in in in many so so
very a good
uh environment for doing this research
is actually mathematics and in
particular computer mathematics
because in other fields it's really hard
to to see when an idea is right or wrong
you you need a human who will sit there
for a long time stare at some chair gbd
output and and wonder whether this is a
good product whether it's a good
mathematical argument or a good physical
argument Etc or not
uh in in this particular
slightly unusual field of of computer
computerized mathematics you get this
basically for free so so people in the
past uh several decades
have basically managed by fight out of
manual effort but also by some
automation
to let's say formally Express
and and formally verify
a lot of non-trivial mathematics so I
may show you some examples
uh but but also like really verified
pieces of code that
Etc like coding libraries
oh so
this is another picture from from that
funny book that I advertised this this
effort of putting mathematics on on this
like solid
a symbolic compute computational
Foundation wasn't without problems so so
even in mathematics they're very big
people like Herbert versus
who
who had different opinions about it like
some of them very more in the sort of
deduction
uh the deduction Direction and some of
them were protesting saying that like if
you mechanized mathematics it will kill
in the uh like the intuition that that
mathematicians are working with so so
this was actually an untraveled process
but it happened like it in in the last
century
after like this
invention of symbolic logic invention of
computers
uh starting to develop AI which by the
way started with how to make the theorem
previous called logic series by Neil and
Simon
uh people started to formalize
mathematics on computers develop
automated and interactive theorem
previous
and do do things with them and you you
will hear a bit more from Martin and
mcclash
and this technology is today already
useful so people have verified
graduate books in mathematics and in
these large projects they have verified
serious compilers like C compilers
operating system micro kernels Hardware
chips transport Finance systems
cryptographic protocols Etc and there
are all these crazy visions that start
with slide nights Etc
I'll I'll just quickly I'm running out
of time show you one example of formal
formal mathematics so so this is a proof
that every student of mathematics has at
some point seen it's it's the
irrationality of the square root of two
and and this is how it looks in a formal
proof language this this is what you do
to to have that piece of text that is
here
formally checked by a computer by by a
machine basically so so that's what
these people are doing what we are doing
is to do these things automatically not
we do not want to write them manually we
we sort of try to
uh through them uh automatically
this is
an example of one of the bigger projects
called the Kepler conjecture I started
to talk about Kepler
so there is a story about him walking
across the Charles bridge in 1610 and
being hit by a snowflake
and as he was hit he started to wonder
how uh like why the snowflake has a
hexagonal shape
and he wrote the treaties about it and
in the treaties he conjectured that the
most compact way of stacking balls
of the same same size is this sort of
orange uh pyramid
so so this big State open and unproved
for for a hundred years then it was
proved in like 1998
but the mathematicians didn't believe
the truth
so what the offers of the proof date was
to fully formally verify this uh long
mathematical proofs
in in computer and on computers that
gave them something like 20 000 lemas of
of this sort of shape
which which took immense amount of time
but what we could show like nine years
ago is is that you can basically
automate a lot of a lot of that stuff
by doing some combinations of machine
learning and automated so so that was
like the first
plausible sign that things could be done
um how much more can I talk
two seconds all right
um so I'll ask you this like these are
like technical details then
showing you can probably download the
slides later uh showing you what are all
the things that you can do and uh you
you combine learning countries I think
uh these are demos again you can click
on them and these are the products that
we have been creating during the six
years of the project
uh this is one of our main system which
really broke the ground
in the sense that it
improved on the best automated CRM
previous in in the field and I I will
not go into it here
what I will just say is that on on the
side you can see one of these feedback
loops between learning and reasoning you
you start with a system which is not
trained and you run it to solve some
problems and you learn from the
solutions that when you run the train
system again and we solve some more
problems and then you learn from it
again if you repeat this six times the
the system improves by some 70 percent
that this is the kind of proof that we
can get today we can get this one in
four minutes
looks like this if you if you write it
manually this is some sort of statistics
about it
uh we we have done other things and I
wanted to show this to Holger but I will
show show him show him offline this is a
system
to which you can give an integer
sequence and it's also running this
feedback loop between like verification
and invention using actual language
models today
and I will skip the language and the
Monte Carlo basically what you give it
is a sequence of integers like times in
this in this case and it will spit out a
program
that is trying to capture the sequence
like in this case these are pseudo
Primes
uh and it can do it in different ways
and sometimes when you have two
different ways how the system thinks
that it expresses some pattern like
Branch for example you can ask the
question can I prove that these two
things are actually the same can I prove
that these two programs are the same and
actually in in some cases
will be talking about it we can do it so
so this is a smt problem encoding the
equality of the of the two programs
and this is a proof that Martin can
produce with the with the Vampire system
of of that particular he called
oh here are some bats but like that I
did actually in 2014 like how far and
how quickly
the this field will move and I will not
linger on that
and let me just thank
and in particular Professor Majid for
welcoming us all here
let's let me thank our sponsors in
particular the European structural funds
uh and the oob projects
my valued team members who were all
grades to work with
our International Partners who helped us
a lot
the the visitors
and most of all I would like to thank
all the international or the people not
just International ones
but the people who returned to Czech
Republic
and and sort of took this risk of coming
from I know Austria or in the
Netherlands Etc and actually survived
here and I think started one of the
first really like International English
speaker groups at uh at the Czech
Technical University oh so thanks a lot
thank you very much I have to say thank
you for organizing such a group for
staying with us and for promoting the
Czech science across Europe we are a
little bit thank you very much also for
the presentation